just going to use this as a classic
example for something you've seen before
but something we want to pay a little
more attention to okay we can use the
sign rule in this question right and
it's easy to see because you look at the
information you've got two sides and two
angles or you've got one angle and you
want to find the other
okay so wherever you've got that pairing
happening that's what makes it a good
candidate for the son world now because
of the way it's phrased and what we're
after which version of the sign rule do
we want because there's two right I mean
they're reciprocals of each other that
they embrace in law okay so because I
want an angle right instead of riding a
on side a I'm gonna ride it the other
way around just so I have my unknown on
the numerator that's the minimum number
of steps so in this triangle I can say
sine theta on the opposite side equals
sine the other angle and it's opposite
side no big deal by the way excuse me
it's really important to write the rule
like that you may immediately see oh I
can just chuck that nine over there and
it's still mathematically true but it's
not the same rule right if you want to
be super ultra sure you can write sand
all over here but um I don't get any
marks I obviously never see it and the
form is so unmistakable it's so distinct
that it's kind of like okay as soon as I
see that I know what you're talking
about
so I'll just rephrase it a little bit so
45 is an example ankle so that's 1 over
root 2 so this is gonna become 9 on 7
root and then you reach me a calculator
and this is obviously going to be some
messy thing let's just go to the nearest
degree
I gotta care about accuracy for the
moment all that much just so that I can
get a ballpark for this thing
yeah cool sixty five point three eight
something something so let's call it 65
and to the nearest great okay now you
look at this do you think with that that
looks good to me that works okay and
sure enough it does but as you know
right the Cyril has this thing called
the empty to his case yeah be Jews case
and this is one of them right in some
explain to me
what is the ambiguous okay okay very
good so this angle here theta equals 65
degrees is only one possible option the
other option would be what would the
other option building 150 choose the
nearest degree okay now the question is
why what is it that there's this extra
option this other thing that the angle
could be okay and the way I'm going to
illustrate it is to appeal back to
something you've been here for a little
while now which is the graph okay so
when you've got the graph of y cosine X
like this now this valley over here of
mine on 72 I didn't calculate it but
what is it actually equal to like that
number it should be some weirdo decimal
points on me 0.9 yeah what weight tell
me something would be a bit of a concern
since it would be outside the range of
it anyway okay so we're at zero point
I've got 0.99 roughly okay so where is
that on my graph okay but because what
does what does this statement mean it's
where does sine theta this when does it
equal to 0.99 etc okay so he's one right
up the top here so point 99 quite close
I'll just pop it there nine seven two
okay so being that that's where the line
goes through you can see there is not
just one solution right there's another
one there it is 65 and 115 okay so
because of the nature of what side looks
like right when you pop in at this line
here it's your calculator theta equals
sine nu sign of her minus 1 etcetera
right well that's what it looks like it
says it's only gonna give you the first
angle it's only gonna give you the first
angle I mean it could give you an
infinite number of solutions but it just
has to pick one okay so picks this one
and it leaves it up to you to work out
okay there's another option okay now we
said this is the ambiguous case but it's
not always ambiguous there are two ways
that you can know that sometimes
actually it's it's not one of the other
it has to be one versus the other
or yeah it has to be one specific one
can someone give me an example when do
you know yes it can't be both angles I'm
locked in to one of the choices Nikaido
say that again okay sure so if I had a
triangle right and I went through all of
this and I got sine theta equals one
there's only one spot in this domain
right we're side P is equal to one
namely 90 degrees okay so fair enough
you're not going to get an ambiguous
case there because well I suppose you
are but it's just a half of the most
cases are the same there's 90 and
there's 180 minus that it's the VGO
there's one case another suggested
okay good so sorry let me just write
these if they're three narrow so case
one is where a sine theta equals one so
feet is equal to nine is the other case
case 2 is where when you check these
down right you have a look at the bigger
angle and it doesn't fit in the Triangle
you've been given for instance if we
just adjusted this a little bit suppose
in one working this triangle but I
couldn't manufacture one where is that
angle if I add it to the obtuse version
it breaks the triangle because of all
these to 185 degrees and I have a third
angle which it has to fit in there
somewhere right so unless that's a
negative angle I'm in some trouble ok
this triangle doesn't exist so case two
is where the obtuse angle is too large
where the obtuse angle if you add it
into all the other things you know it
exceeds the angle sum of a triangle okay
so they're the easiest ones to spot
there's a trickier one case three it's a
bit more subtle yeah okay so they may
actually say to you they might provide
you a like an actual statement that says
the ingre must be limited or the angle
must be acute so there might be some
kind of domain restriction I suppose I
kind of include that kind of on this
right min-soo Jordan if you wanted us to
say oh okay sure yeah alright so if I
have another side like this one down
here okay that gives you more
information right so think about it this
way you know when we say for a triangle
proof right for congruent if I have a
triangle like this I don't know three
six eight okay and then I draw another
triangle okay these triangles and all of
their angles must be exactly the same
right because there's no other way that
you can fit those three sides together
such that you get different triangles
okay now what this is saying over here
is that with this amount of information
I can make two triangles right I can
actually draw it like this angle here
won't look like this in life
be going off an another angle like that
right so therefore if I know what all
three sides are then I know exactly what
the angle must be so it's not like a CEM
in this or the other okay there's one
more actually case of thinking of I'm
just gonna write it down for you when
you have the sides okay see I don't know
if you notice when we were looking at
the reason why a tangent is
perpendicular to the radius at the point
of contact around a circle okay we
noticed that when you have pairs of
sides right a bigger angle bigger angle
means that the site it's opposite it
like please change right a bigger angle
means that the side must be bigger that
kind of makes sense doesn't it like
literally as you take the two sides of
it okay so here we go I don't have three
arms so you and I drove through rulers
either so you just have to imagine right
so here are two sides and the third side
is joining up the top here like in
between these two bits at the top okay
so if I have a very very small angle
between these two sides right then the
side that's opposite that really tiny
angle at the bottom okay sorry I should
hold up so you consume the sight its
opposite then Society at the top will be
really small right and as I increase the
size of the angle this side also gets
bigger does that make sense right so in
the same way you can argue then if this
side try this angle is opposite a big
sign right and this angle is obvious at
a smaller side okay
this angle must be bigger than this
angle does that make sense
we said again okay because this side is
bigger than this side the angle that
spacing it must match right so a big
side big angle smaller side smaller
angle okay so if what you get here right
so this can actually take you both ways
so case three is um comparing relative
side lengths
so this can go one of both ways right
suppose when you do sign me up right if
this angle over here ends up being
smaller than this one something has gone
wrong right can you see that like
suppose I calculate it Oh theta over
here is like 31 degrees okay but then
you have a small side AAPIs sorry a
small angle opposite a big side right
and a big angle opposite or small so it
doesn't match up okay or it can go vice
versa if I have this angle over here and
then I look at the obtuse angle right
but the original angles got a bigger
side facing it okay it won't make sense
beach side big angle small side small
angle it just so happens in this case
that both work can you see that both
work
either of these options are bigger than
what you've got here so either these
options work because they are opposite
the bigger side okay so you've got all
these different ways that you can
determine what should the angle actually
be should it be both is it truly
ambiguous or do you have some other
information that locks you into it being
one or the other